some great info there from Sally and of
course the Flood Control District thank
you for that 100 for a high for the day
today that matched right where we should
be for this time of the year 81
overnight and low also matched our
normal for this time of year 113 is the
record on this date set way back in 1939
and don't worry well it gets 113 soon
enough it's actually in the extended
forecast 103 for Santana Hills right now
we begin for the northwest part of
valley sky canyon providence all you
guys if they're watching you this
evening thank you so much 102 for all
the ante the east side of 105 for
sunrise mountain and same goes for
Whitney ranch and Green Valley currently
107 for Henderson hot out there
mountain's edge southwest part of town
Rhodes ranches well 103 for you 100 even
for prop just a digit to below that for
Sandy Valley hundred for for Boulder
City and lastly coming in at 109 this
evening meanwhile our Doppler network
again not finding any precip here
however we are tracking some monsoon
moisture that will come in from Mexico
but really affect Arizona on the Friday
Saturday timeframe it will come close
enough we're talking mid-level moisture
where it could move its way a little bit
more westward but really if we get
anything it'll be isolated mainly dry
thunderstorms wind and dry lightning
could be a possibility if it makes its
way westward into Clark County or the
Colorado River right now it looks like
most of it will really stay off into
Arizona and in Mojave County and central
portions of America Arizona the big
story of course this weekend is going to
be the heat there are your records for
Saturday Sunday and Monday will come
close to it don't think we'll reach them
but we're still looking at 112 Saturday
113 on Sunday and Monday at 112 degrees
that could be the hottest temps of the
year at least we hope so
we hope so this weekend and we overdone
wood right 75 overnight clear a nice
Southwest breezes still around at least
early on and the evening single digits
expected late night tonight and tomorrow
morning and then more heat tomorrow 106
breezy at time so what is that entirely
going away tomorrow but there won't be
as strong as what we've seen lately
we'll keep some of those breezes around
through the afternoon tomorrow 105 for
the lakes along with North Las Vegas and
mountain's edge hundred 5'4 Aliante
along with sky canyon Centennial hills
109 sunrise mountain
8:4 up greenvalley 104 for Boulder City
Laughlin you're coming at 112 degrees so
here is your extended forecast now a
little wind also for fraud as well that
heat warning starts on Saturday lasts
all the way through Monday and guess
what more wind and decline of those
temperatures fly late by it's how we get
to Tuesday that's your weather update
Denise back OD